and now to events in Wimbledon and that
crash outside a school there in the
London borough of Merton our Sports
presenter Jackie beltraau is on the
scene and joins us now on the phone
Jackie what more can you tell us
yes this is a very small Road around
just off Wimbledon common where the pond
is located it's a really really narrow
road very quiet not a main road at all I
can see about eight ambulances in front
of me blue lights flashing there is a
place called Knox we can't get closer to
the school the study school faces onto
the common which is part of Wimbledon
golf course as well I've spoken to a
policeman who'd also not been beyond the
end chord and he said there are
casualties they are taking them away in
the ambulances to hospital one by one he
couldn't say exactly what had happened
but it was a serious traffic incident he
believed it was an out of control car
one vehicle involved that's what he told
me I can't confirm that because I cannot
see the school from where I'm standing
but no one can and there are so many
ambulances lined up on Camp Road
alongside the Pub the fox and grapes
which is that well known to people who
live in Wimbledon there must be at least
as many ambulances behind me fire trucks
several fire trucks and many many uh
police cars the roads all around the
common have been closed off and I've had
to come across here on foot
and there are lots of well look like
parents standing behind me and other
smaller children
just waiting for some news uh the
policeman in front of me have not been
up to the scene they are literally
Manning the police Cordon so difficult
to know exactly what's happened
um
but we do know there are casualties and
they are being taken to hospital one by
one no ambulances have driven past me as
yet I've been here for about five
minutes
um none have come past me as yet
um that is pretty much all I can tell
you right now at several camera Crews
have arrived as you can imagine
and
multiple police officers just Manning
Discord and
and this entire road but as I said very
very small Road in Wimbledon common very
quiet it's not really enough space for
two cars if I'm honest
um very hard to know how anyone would
have got up to any kind of speed it's
almost like a one-way system
um going around the school
of course imagine how this might have
happened really